awesome hey how it's gone so uh yeah sir
I am zypher if if you know me probably
owned by that but since they're all here
and we're all friends and glee Michael
and I really love what we have in our
community it's kind of special in that
they're very few communities that are
open to sharing and having events like
this and like as part of that part of
the team that runs this is confer you I
with some other great people of you here
and Glenn he'll be speaking later and I
also helped run one of the bigger front
end meetups back home in Melbourne and i
really love up and saw some of that we
can share our code and we can all learn
from each other and really build on the
shoulder of giants and as part of that I
country the projects like a lib
sassanids us but this is anas a stalk
I'm not here to tell you how amazing
sasses but they should use a SAS or not
this is actually a story and it's my
story and it's a story of all about how
my life got flipped turned upside down
I'd like to take a minute just sit right
there I'd tell how became a real program
so I want to start with a smaller side
so back home in australia until the end
of primary schools about the age of 12
13 your entire schooling you work in our
pencil you never use pens and the idea
is that in your final year of primary
school you go through a stink will
depend license and you have to prove
that your handwriting is legible enough
that you can use a pen and not make
mistakes and uh so I got my pen license
I was the last one to get my pen less
instead of my entire level and to this
day I'm pretty sure I got our obligation
because I deserved it and since about
the age of 12 and so if we think back
this is like looking back in my life
this is kind of I started programming
very early know by the age of like eight
or nine I was very plainly things like
basic making like really simple bit back
bitmap pixel games that kind of stuff
and then not long before that not long
after that I learned HTML because it's
kind of really simply need a notepad my
computer is really terrible and this
kind of worked and I she was about it
was about this time that I got my pen
license so at this point i could
probably pretty confidently like to
relatively basic languages i get some
stuff done yo comped earlier high school
i start messing around with like hello
world apps and really kind of
command-line apps in like python and
moving on to things like c and then in
very early high school i discovered
flash i just got to blue my vines i
could actually see what i was doing no
more hello world No More CL eyes like
really pretty interactive stuff other
than flash actionscript like that kind
of blew my mind Zac object orientated
programming inside this action script is
a pretty language there later in high
school we had a part of our schooling we
learn like Excel and Word and like the
built-in like vba language in that and
from that moves like some of us are
really curious that playing a visual
basic and then you know this web person
kept eating at me so I found out his PHP
and got involved in like sitepoint stuff
and our big on PHP at the time so I
learn how to play with the web then
unique comes around and like we all have
to do java the web car disappears for me
for a while but i can't i can't get away
i keep going back to it so I learned
jquery
not JavaScript jQuery I'll proudly say
that so then I got a job writing PHP and
jquery for a company after dropping out
of uni and I started messing with a
c-sharp was like an internal project we
had that people started using foolishly
and then we moved on to some Ruby stuff
and then like I couldn't get way from
this web thing later on I start working
like an agency moved mostly to front end
stuff i started doing ere you ç sister
HTML got really excited yeah something
some javascript stuff that eventually
leads to things like node and then like
I got really the performance and anyone
like worth their salt performance wants
to know everything about how everything
is working so you like engine X and a
passion you're tweaking things and like
how can I make this faster oh then it's
like our map start getting bigger and
bigger bigger companies like this
setting is crazy it's all over the place
how do we how do we manage this just
stop playing with sass and they removed
for to today and like I was using react
and like this all seems kind of crazy
like who does all this all these
languages and but actually have been
really simple because they all spring
from the stink like c-style languages so
we look at it something like a C++ for
example which is like one of those big
boy languages and we look at me see
things like all right we can figure out
we got like a variable assignment here
we've got like a function like that
we're taking a string you're adding the
input of the function to another string
or defined and returning that and just
calling that function it's pretty simple
code for like this like any language I
don't know kind of weird thing and this
is like we see like the string keyword
which is like we assume as a type like
we know our strings are that's all right
that's pretty bad it's nothing too
difficult but then you take things look
at javascript and like let's pretty much
the same thing right you got a variable
yet the VAR keyword a set of the string
like about the type anymore we're still
with the function the function name the
function parameter we're still plussing
two strings together returning I strand
calling a function that's like all right
well this is pretty straightforward
we've got a PHP and like this is almost
exactly the same thing we've dropped
afar and added like dollar signs and
otherwise its exact same code take this
to SAS exact same thing like we've taken
the function return web with that symbol
in front of them but yeah under the
covers are all kind of the same things
what this same
heritage lanikai you moved towards you
you are fast your language is anything
like Ruby where it's like all this
things made the code readable a now gone
and you kind of like if you've seen like
the previous examples you have rats
going on but jumping into like this like
all right they've taken it too far so
it's like it's not it's not hard this
programming things actually really easy
like that language is really language is
so easy but actually the whole thing of
like learning how to program is hard
like what is a ruby isn't whatsapp HP is
it was a javascript ism and so the last
four years I transitioned almost
primarily to entirely front-end
theyselves the hardest one market finds
most enjoyable problem and things like
an interesting start running meetups and
hang out entirely more fronting crowds
then we'd hire more developers in my
current job and they'd never seen me
right back anchored so you can send
questions is like you can do this weird
debates like is X even program you CSIS
exit programming like what I wanted to
do a real code why you're doing this
front-end thing like you seem so smart
what are you doing with your life this
is like this this is pretty pervasive
and I think about this in like what is
your programming it's like in the front
end with the lowest maintainability
scaling issues that we do on the back
end we're so he's doing a bunch of
operations here we care about we care
about performance yeah and it we have
two things like they have to worry about
we have to worry about compatibility
they have to wear BEC compatibility or
cross-platform like that code they write
it on PHP runs in that server it's
always going to work on that server very
little is going to break it and we had
this like a whole array of things such
different browser to browser versions
like a lot of a significantly harder and
so I pondered on this for one really
kind of bugged me and I bumped into this
mention of the dunning-kruger effect and
it's kind of a two-part thing and one is
like as people who only know a little
bit about a thing can extrapolate what
they know and realize yeah well this is
easy like I can make a round corner
service I can make like a pie chart out
of gradient so I can feel this thing and
I could do like there's so much I can do
because I can do this really tiny thing
and they don't have you don't know
enough to know how much you don't know
until you start doing it and we start
list and browse the whole time like this
one's really simple when you start
messing with it like
is really hard and the other side of
this and the really kind of toxic part
that I find is people who are who are
good at something assume everybody is as
good as they are and so they belittle
what they know it's like well I know
this everybody knows this so it can't be
that hard and you put these things
together and you have like the whole
idea of like front-end ebbs people time
when our programmers and we believe
we're not programmers this is kind of
this thing that's kind of bugged me for
a while it's got an inspiration behind
this talk of like wow why are we
considered programs so in 2011 i joined
copy nine on designs and we had this
like ad hoc look was very developed
during very small team we had like
multiple generations of the UI and like
as you can imagine PHP devs riding
front-end code it was everything you
imagined it was an unpleasant was a mess
and I joined as a back-end developer
saying that when you care about the
front end I'm there this is what I want
to do so come around 2012 and we decided
all right when he does responsive thing
is kind of cool we need to do it so he
did a responsive rebrand started working
on this thing and I convinced them we
got to do SAS like used it before it's
incredible he's going to save us so much
time and we started building our
internal and internal framework based
off foundation and because Royal
Engineers we build a framework for
engineers and as a result things were
good for a while we understood we were
doing like our PHP guys can write our
CSS and like it worked and it was nice
and like everyone could take second
languages we're using like using SAS
like an API for the most things but as
this happened we got more and more code
and as we all know compilation times
just like blew out like I won't pull at
like six minute eight minute compilation
times brought into my compass magic but
that like tuna compilation times was
kind of brutal and I back in this one no
part of its like what are you doing it
used to work for us she CSS so I we had
enough and we SAT la vista latest thing
called lib sass the idea behind it was
like it was the Ruby such project taking
a C++ an assumption like of it since
it'll just be faster like there are
other really great benefits of this but
the big thing was like we can put in C
we'll make it fast of all the problems
and then Iraq have super fast ass
alright we played with it for a long
time and we just couldn't get there like
the basic phone mental features were
missing so you can even polyfill I was
like ah variables of Oregon like that's
a problem so we kind of played this in a
bandit because a killer backbone we want
to come back to it and so later that
year I went to the first caps s in san
francisco and this was my chance like I
had questions for these people so i was
there i ran into chris Epstein who is
one of the main riders of SAS along with
Natalie and I ran into Hampton who was
running camps ass but also it was like
the original inventor of SAS and the
person who had the vision for lib SAS in
the first place and then I ran into Erin
who was the person Hampton convinced to
write lips ass so I had questions for
like why why is that in nerd aren't i
fronted to change nerd like this is days
are like grunt to the thing and like why
not make it a nerd things we don't play
together have one big nice things really
know it's faster than Ruby let's just do
this and I was I also had a head full of
steam like I'm gonna come back on a
write this like I've started thinking
about it pretty intensely we'd run
accessorize full time for to use at this
point bring this framework and I talked
to Hampton he goes you could totally do
that you could definitely write this a
nerd but just know how much time this is
this the next to use your life like
there's so many edge case you have no I
how much work is going into making sash
do it says does and to start messing
with it none like well I don't this
fills back at that in Kruger fact it
feels easy but it's not like all right
now look so why is it taking so long
then why is this pretty bad for years
like it was almost no progress and it's
like well the intersection of people who
write C++ and CSS is zero like nobody
cares this happens because I'm paying
somebody and I've stopped paying him and
I stopped happening it's like all right
all that it's legit so come back home
2014 I'm like I don't think I have
enough of my life to write a note
version of this like so just about the
bull I could I'll just I'll do some say
this let's get it working I've taught
myself much languages let's just do it
completely well I didn't know a single
thing about C++ I could never analyzed
supposed to compiled it was really scary
to me like C++ is like that's the
boy language like he'll write operating
systems and games and like this is it
when I think my programming is like I
miss my on the web but these guys are
really these as a building things it was
kind of scary thing for me a long time I
put it off for a long time I purpose but
figure I let's just do this ragama go
start the adventure and we got to get
started like thinking back my university
days like what is the scary thing my
suppose what what do I know I know it's
a compiled language which like for most
of like the server's like it's all run
time it's kind of happens as you do it's
pretty it's interpreted what languages
have a doob lot more work initially is a
lot of upfront costs but it's kind of
weather run faster and there was this
linker and it linked to things yeah I
actually still don't know what that does
really i'm not close to some pain I
don't need to know I don't so there are
make files so I'm try to think back to
like surely we can't be to diverge from
front and the back end like okay I do
the same thing so I'm thinking back like
so make files are essentially grunt for
C or for unix people like before those
JavaScript there was Mike and then we
decided laughter JavaScript grant the
grunt make you know preprocessor
directives like this is a he's a
relatively complicated and I don't
understand him completely but everyone
looked through the lips I source code
noises he's include everywhere is
included I'm like all this is obvious
this is just like import right this is
we've done this before there are some
differences with the MER spot like I
don't you dinner this is going to work
the same way I'm is strictly typed which
is open first example it's like we're
going to define our types like our
coolest place virus string we sorted
good how many times can i really be yeah
so it's kind of the same thing we kind
of I get a sharp like this it is just
functions of variables as pretty
convinced this should be too hard got
ahead of files and these are whoa sir
java kicked in skip this version cool
so we have our header files and our
header file sir I try to think it was
like like doesn't your bow or mpm like
they're not but they're on the way they
express intent it's like this won't work
without this thing that I've told you I
need like all right well I already miss
them too much I'm gonna get by without
touching them so it's copy and paste
what i see so you do a quick sesh lesson
so the big feature missing from SAS that
we really needed with SAS maps and so
sassa the data structure called lists
unless we're kind of see in CSS is like
space separated thing like any kind of
shorthand like paddings or margins
essentially we should was list inside of
SAS and we have a bunch of list
functions we can find a list of this
becomes like an array essentially being
cool ends and say give me the first item
in this unlike other languages it's one
indexed I zero indexed but it's pretty
simple weeks we've all done is kind of
stuff so we have maps and maps a kind
like your hash map or impeach page still
in array so Christ simple here we have a
list of values we have a hash of values
the map values we can like name the
thing we want which is better than we
can just say I get me this thing like by
name and this like it we scream at this
for years build one of the since ass for
so long and I finally landed but live
SAS was just so far off the ball that we
this is the thing we need to dump I
framework was based off maps I figure if
we could just do maps then we gonna we
can get there we'll touch there this is
my girls on a work on a bringing SAS
maps into set until obsess trying to
figure it out and uh so the way this
works is every think would suspect like
I said test Suites a whole different
project and all it takes is a bunch of
SAS files and turns when the CSS files
and compares them like if the stuff
you've given the same sass file if
you're British the same CSS Ruby says
does you've passed so I call right easy
so a first step was creating a poor
quest like let's create all the all the
specs of the map functions the big map
API let's write all the specs we know
it's going to work and this got merged
and like all right like getting stuff
motion up and sauce is hard so have a
team wants like once your stuff that's
pretty cool so getting that PR Matt
merge made me feel really good like I
admit I seem like a little giddy at the
time was like wow this happened so it
gave me this rush of confidence and in
that moment I felt like this possible
maybe I can do this yeah
spicing is easy i got this this is this
good fun is easy now boys a doubt creeps
in and you're like they've put their
trust in you you better not screw up and
then it sinks in I didn't write C++ I I
turned SAS into CSS my cat walking on my
keyboard could have mistakenly done this
but it's okay I've got this has nothing
to lose like they're not expecting a
pull request like if I pull it off it'll
be a fantastic and surprising but what
if the pr sucks what if they can tell
them afford immediately one of my shitty
code is out there for whole world to see
forever we're not going to do i like all
rights so what if it sucks all right I
tried they're good people they don't
want it to help just do it I've talked
to them it's okay like it's all going to
be all right so I'm going to get into
how I started so not knowing see I jump
into the code base and I figured all
right maps are kind of like lists like
we see in the purchase same thing so
I've just started throwing some code at
the wall like let's see if it sticks so
this is our samples from original PR and
I out it take a short look just so you
can find the pattern what's going on
here it's a bit bit more of it don't
lean in the code but we can see they've
got bring in maps in here done it again
same kind of thing and this is what I
call like CP DT this is a pattern that i
use to really get this sorted and what
it is copy paste driven development like
like we just take a short look like
anyway you saw the keyword map you saw
the keyword list because maps are like
lists I figure if I can just make maps
do a lister then what if i'm a bit let's
push the same thing the slight
difference here is like you maps the
keys and values not just values like
otherwise it's like two lists right
let's move forward so the next one was a
cedd so usually when you write code and
you get an error like we've seen SAS let
go you know it's out of it's out of
bounds you've asked so a third element
the recent third element yeah useful
error message you kind of find your code
c++ when things go wrong things go wrong
look just like it's broken figure it out
I'm like what am i doing how do I get
how I get pasta sick so go do this I
discovered a sink with gdb which I just
overflowed and just got a missed I know
three commands and three commands are
always using that work every time but
you some like this and it's like all
right all right okay sure I'm seeing OS
some sink symbol I'm saying very scary
words in there what have I broken
whatever done yeah well 11
there and a half there it is so that's
the thing it's actually broken this
tells me off somewhere in this print
thighs function is like an issue this is
the stack trace 'ok most languages to
give you this is useful thing and you
get there eventually a bit like yeah
it's still scary every time i see that i
kind of panic a bit so that's compilat
orange of development and I'm this is
because it is a compiled language like
it knows when things are wrong for the
most part before they're actually wrong
then kind of stopped you and if it
wasn't for this I don't think I ever
would have shipped my lips I stuff in
the first place because I think I no
idea what I was doing this is like weeks
and weeks of work eventually had a pull
request had some help people I work with
who were great and uh so I did this and
Wow bye-bye a series of like unfortunate
and Portage's their behalf they merge
this code and I product explicitly say
you probably should emerge this like
this is a start someone better than I am
can fix this but take what I've done
like I don't like I says they are don't
write C C++ but they're excited who
starts out like they wanted emerges to
go to that there's big pork quest people
really happy and it's a really big
problem the big form was I'm terrible at
sea and so when we looked at while I was
writing the map functions i was riding
him like like two sets of lists if you
know a basic computer science a terrible
idea this is like the map get function
turned to SAS but but sip athis code was
doing it's like oh you have a map and a
key was looped through the entire map
each time find the key the matches bring
value back it's pretty naive we've all
done it before but this is crazy slower
this is terrible code and it was so slow
in the fact that thing the first
iteration was a couple orders magnitude
slower than Ruby so no matter how fast c
is like there's no substitute for
terrible code so ox why they ship this
and the thing is like performance as a
feature to them nope i open an issue
saying like i know it was on this think
is terrible but uh wind up we have
multiple iterations i'm coming here is
saying like I know why it's broken right
Darnell how to fix it and see an ad fix
it in JavaScript
took a bit of research and we file got a
second PR and stuck down a third or
fourth iteration at this point it's like
lightning fast but one of the fastest
parts of lib sites like this map thing
it's got a lot of work into it it's like
a lot of work people perform me like
people who wrote really fussy libraries
and I bench alert had user api's and
it's perfect fit sure it's really
important to us the community wanted
maps they didn't care how fast they
where it's much better use them so
[ __ ] something like this this is
comparison of going around like lib SAS
is two times slower than / CSS written
in JavaScript I'm wearing C so we're
doing special isn't really terribly
wrong well they're just a really great
engineering and like we know this we
know it's slow it wasn't really
concerned make it true phosphorus like
we're bring on the laurels of CC is fast
so we'll be just be fast by having being
in C and doesn't always work out but
like we give people the features they
wanted so we've all seen stuff like this
and like we've all seen it in regards to
CSS but more accurately it's like things
that don't understand I don't know how
to do a thing it's painful like I don't
know what I'm doing was he yelling at me
how do i fix this so yeah this is like
the one of the new iterations and we can
see in the previous version where like a
second or so slower than like rubies ass
and a new version I think this is the
version we were actually equivalent we
got as fast as Ruby SAS was super
excited well I was because I fixed my
terrible code so come around the tour
2005 this is out there and um through
continued continued poor decisions on
behalf of Hampton I'm now one half of
the core team of lube SAS ah one-third
start an OC by the way we've added a new
contributor now which is really awesome
the team is growing I'm most another
project lead of nerd sauce which is a
JavaScript project that's mostly see so
that's the continuing theme I'm up here
on stage in front of you all talking
about how terrible em as a programmer
but yes still a programmer and so I've
talked about these techniques for how
you can take what you know in SAS and
JavaScript and write like big boy stuff
like C and see if I see not be afraid
and like words a cheap so let's write
some code
I sinner so we're going to write some
lips s today so yeah clap when it works
so this is a compact function it's
pretty simple or does the text takes a
list so we have a list here of we have a
list here of values you know some truth
you some folks who knows from JavaScript
false is false null is false the guy
just takes this list now if you've
actually passed in a list having
personal issues return the list for
years like no up but it's going to loop
through your list find things that
looked Ruthie add them to a new listing
return on your list it's like returning
the stuff is probably Nolan didn't mean
to have in the first place so that's
cool this is the SAS version of it and
if we run it we can see it works like
false is gone and null is gone this is
cool work turning SAS into c plus
bhaskar and then executing that and
bring back out SAS a super slow like we
want native methods run like this end
function like and these loops how fast
these because they're in C++ so that's a
let's bring some the c++ the way I would
program obsess so if there's anyone here
who like who's bosses are controlled by
the youth lib toss not just they should
leave this is the house is how we write
this covered it's not very personal way
to lose facing code right here so like
we could probably guess this thing is
empty good functions as a functions file
cool so the one thing we do know like
when I know a lot of sass so for me this
is kind of easy I know I need something
this is like a function called index so
if you look like index index is a
function in SAS it's kind of like
finally we're in disarray this thing
happens let's keep looking where
anything's look like these that look
around index function alright cool so we
can see this kind of looks like a texan
a list if the list is empty return the
list sure we've done this before loop
over the list if it equals x we pass the
internet number cool that's kind of like
some what we're doing we're looping over
taking a list of returning a value what
we want to do we want to turn a list not
a number and that's similar to the
append function which is actually right
here so what's this doing this is a lot
of code let's talk about that right now
so it's like all right so we want
something it's kind of like index so
it's just copy and paste this we only
wanted to call compact not index let's
just a change that the compact we don't
want to value we just on the list so to
get rid of the value all right so we
just guess that this is creating a list
we don't want value so they can go away
so this means be sure cool so this is
comparing if the value at i equals the
value we passed it we don't have a
values obviously don't want this I
really want this like so what we're
checking for is like existing truthy all
right if it's truly you want it we don't
so to your incest like is this true
right if this is true then do a thing so
so such a stirring and number stop what
we want below if you see the pattern
here like it's very similar to our SAS
code of like loop through if do
something return so in a pen just kind
of like the list stuff we need right
it's like results well you know result
of same in every language that's thing
we're returning so let's create one of
those setting a length we don't know the
lengths let's get rid of that just
defaulted deserve sure whatever that
means cool so what we need to do is add
a new thing to list a like we know this
is going to do this let's figure it out
the odd thing to list sure it's probably
going to work we don't have V but V is
this value right so let's just copy and
paste that it's probably gonna work I'm
gonna return the results like this part
we know where programmers cool this
looks like almost exactly like I'll SAS
code
oh I miss one day I compact what I
could've been bad I do have the license
but I upgraded and they doesn't work in
three-point oh my stuff's Birkin um sir
all right let's run this again actually
no it's not run graduate compile our
code so we're not grunt file or I'll
make file that looks cool oh I compiled
did not expect that all right so comment
out our compact functions when we're
using our code let's run it I'd save
that
No
there we go so yeah it's spitting out
the word of compact which that we want
it all so it actually not finding our
functions at all sorry I done something
wrong look our index function what's
this index sick sure that's a search
four letter code base ah there we go
we've missed some stuff all right turn
index into compact whereas we missed
let's string index now we just did that
yeah there we go stick your header files
all right it's Rick impalas o this ere
drug development right in front so
contact all right so obviously there's a
thing called compact some wasn't exists
but when our index exists so let's
search for index what do we missed these
don't look right that's on the score
index nope
there we go you can tell us in their
comeback in the earth
let's do it hey no air is it compiled
but it hasn't done a thing we've noticed
like know what our folks is still there
why is false there obviously our if
check isn't cutting it just go back to
our code
it's the head of file right so I missing
something here this if check is
obviously failing like things that are
folks are coming in true so it's like a
look for those oh how people doing false
is false there we go now we're doing it
so if this room is false we want if it's
really one if it's true right like it's
not false yeah all right we've just C++
wish it was a jerk that's how most of
slips us gets written sir running out of
time so we just come to today we have a
new release loose ass coming out it is
now the fast food processor out there
we're now at a narrow after three major
versions or almost a complete feature
parity the new version which is on this
list there should be a complete feature
parity with some edge cases I can hang
out with these great people this is a
Hampton Chris like this thanks these
people that I'm a will be up here and
tell you about this stuff and you can
use lips esterday know could have
thanked Natalie who is in approach the
person who runs assassin does or
language design for SAS and like I
couldn't have done this like I would
never put that PR up if I didn't think
like that be supportive like having met
them before I having known the SS
community like there's some great people
in this community like has spoken today
owner include inna were being like since
meeting them off doing this work I Know
Who I am really supportive like the
stuff we're doing and they're excited
for it and you're the other lips ask him
it is like Marcel is done most of this
new version by himself he's been out of
control Adele who runs nodes ass
eventually passed it on to me I still
contributes heavily and I newest
contributor marcin who's just come to
both projects to do lots of great work
for a long time and like passing on the
buck from what Hampton two teammates I
come in help us out like you're doing
good work be part of the team this is it
thanks like you can do this to stay
sassy